bleibt zu hause darum baten politiker
prominente ärzte krankenpfleger und
viele andere seit tagen dabei bleibt es
nun nicht mehr
ab morgen gelten im ganzen land
strengere regeln in den nächsten zwei
wochen darf man nur noch aus wichtigem
grund vor die tür
maximal zu zweit oder mit der eigenen
familie
das ist ein tiefer einschnitt in die
persönliche freiheit aber er bringt
vielleicht klarheit wo zuletzt förderer
alle verwirrung herrschte helfen diese
ausgangs beschränkungen jetzt nachhaltig
beim kampf gegen das corona virus wir
halten die menschen sie aus wie hält das
ganze land das aus und wie lange darüber
wollen wir reden mit diesen gästen armin
laschet cdu ministerpräsident von
nordrhein westfalen
die psychologin ulrike lücken
der moderator johannes b kerner
frank ulrich montgomery vorsitzender des
welt ärzte bundes
und der spd bundesfinanzminister und
vizekanzler
olaf scholz sie sind zu gast bei maybrit
illner und einen guten abend auch den
gästen in der runde natürlich neue lage
auch am heutigen sonntag erste frage an
den vizekanzler olaf scholz
ausgangssperre kontaktsperre was gab es
noch ausgangs beschränkungen
kontaktverbot irgendwie haben die bürger
nicht mehr so richtig durch gesehen ist
das jetzt die klare botschaft an alle
die auch jeder versteht dass heute
glaube ich eine sehr klare botschaft
entstanden aus dem gespräch der
mitglieder der bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der länder um den
bürgermeistern der stadt starten
wir haben festgelegt dass es im
öffentlichen raum kontakt begrenzungen
gibt und hat verbote um es ganz klar zu
sagen weil wir durchsetzen wollen dass
möglichst wenig leute gleichzeitig sich
begegnen dort in der öffentlichkeit also
die ansage ist das einer der alleine
lehnt wer alleine lebt mit jemand anders
zusammengehen kann das ansonsten
familien miteinander sich bewegen können
dass man auch sport machen kann weil wir
unbedingt erreichen wollten dass man
auch weiterhin die frische luft kann das
ist glaub ich angesichts der vielen
beschränkungen ganz ganz wichtig aber
das eben alle so voneinander entfernt
miteinander solidarisch sind dass wir
uns nicht zu oft anstecken abstand ist
das neue sozial armin laschet ist bei
uns der ministerpräsident von nordrhein
westfalen
herr laschet ist das jetzt so eine art
ausgangssperre leigt also man hat sich
heute auf weitere ausgangs
beschränkungen verständigt es ist keine
ausgangssperre
denn die ausgangssperre geht von der
idee aus soll man seine wohnung
verlassen dürfen ja oder nein
und dann unter welchen bedingungen ein
kontaktverbot sagt man soll möglichst
abstand halten zu menschen im
öffentlichen raum wie olaf scholz das
gerade beschrieben hat und
ausgangssperre ist falsch denn die leute
sollen ihre wohnung verlassen sie sollen
an die frische luft gehen
aber sie sollen möglichst nicht auf
andere treffen sondern alleine sich
draußen bewegen
und insofern ist das glaube ich ein
gut auf konsens dem wir heute erzielt
haben wie leicht oder wie schwer lässt
sich das kontrollieren und was werden
sich der polizisten anhören müssen und
was davon werden sie glauben
herr scholz ist immer noch ein bisschen
mehr geld ist ja na ja also das ist
natürlich nicht einfach 80 millionen
menschen jetzt im öffentlichen raum zu
beobachten mit wie vielen leuten sind
sie zusammen
ich finde es muss trotzdem jetzt für
jeden spürbar sein dass die örtlichen
ordnungsämter da auch durchgreifen das
betrifft insbesondere wenn gruppen von
15 leuten zusammen stehen da haben wir
viele jugendliche in der letzten woche
gesehen
mein eindruck ist dass hat freitag und
samstag drastisch nachgelassen in allen
deutschen städten merkt man die menschen
haben verstanden worum es geht es gibt
eine große eigenverantwortung und das
muss man anerkennen und die wenigen
unvernünftigen die müssen auch
sanktionen spüren und da haben wir
bußgelder im maximalfall bis zu 25.000
euro
also man muss jetzt ordnungsamt und
polizei signalisieren es geht um leben
und tod es geht um eine ganze menge aber
mein eindruck ist die menschen machen
das mit und die polizei ist auch dankbar
für eine mehr oder weniger klare linie
jetzt ja jesus la geregelt und wir alle
länder haben das jetzt auch noch in den
ländergesetzen so umgesetzt
frank ulrich montgomery ist bei uns chef
des wild ärzte bundes hermann comrie sie
waren gegen eine harte ausgangssperre
das haben sie auch gut für argumentiert
können wir mit dieser kontaktsperre
können sie kann man damit jetzt
einigermaßen leben ja ich finde der
armin laschet hat das hervorragend
erklärt es kommt eben nicht darauf an
ihn um jeden preis zu verbieten die
wohnung zu verlassen sondern es kommt
darauf an ihnen die anreize zu nehmen
ins restaurant in die kneipe zu gehen
und es kommt darauf an ihnen klar zu
machen
sie dürfen draußen alles machen solange
sie den abstand einhalten und bestimmte
andere regeln einhalten das ist ein
großer unterschied bei der
ausgangssprache hätten wir das problem
gehabt die begründen wir über die wieder
aufheben denn wir werden eine längere
zeit jetzt mit dem corona virus zu leben
müssen und da hätte ich mir große
schwierigkeiten gedacht wie sie
begründen dass sie die ausgangssperre
wieder aufheben um zu verhindern dass
ihr danach einen rebound phänomen
kriegen also dann plötzlich ein
ein starkes ansteigen wenn wir alle
wieder raus dürfen
ich finde den weg jetzt maßvoll und
richtig wünsche mir dass das in allen
bundesländern in gleicher weise jetzt
auch so umgesetzt wird und wir mal ein
gutes signal auch aus dem föderalismus
herausgekommen darüber reden wir gleich
noch mal da hat es ein bisschen
diskussion heute gegeben aber unbedingt
begrüßen wir wollen wir frau professor
ulrike lügen sie sind psychologin hier
an der humboldt universität in berlin
diese menschenleeren straßen sind jetzt
doch ein gespenstischer anblick für
viele macht uns das zusätzlich an
naja angst ist ja zunächst einmal ein
sehr gesundes grundgefühl was uns vor
gefahren waren und sollen insofern es
ist nachvollziehbar dass in dieser neuen
auch unbekannten situationen viele
menschen auch mit anschlüssen unwohlsein
einer möglichkeit einem ängstlichen
gefühl reagieren ja also die korona
krise als solche betrifft uns alle und
in unseren praxen arbeiten wir
regelmäßig mit menschen die sich in
persönlichen krisen befinden und die
psychologische krisenintervention ist
eine sehr gute möglichkeit diese
menschen noch aus den krisen
herauszuführen
sie haben gerade schon gesagt angst ist
etwas normales und auch etwas sehr gutes
eine übertriebene angst ist ein problem
woher wissen wir jetzt aber in dieser
situation ob unsere ängste übertrieben
sind
ich glaube die frage kann man so gar
nicht eindeutig beantworten denn niemand
von uns hat erfahrungen mit dieser neuen
situation ich glaube aber wir menschen
sind ja sehr lernfähig und wir lernen
gerade eine ganze menge wir sehen das
auch dass die politik ihre
entscheidungen stück für stück
adjustiert und so werden auch die
menschen sich an diese neue situation
ihren neuen alltag gewöhnen
da bin ich sehr zuversichtlich wir
werden uns darin einrichten und werden
dass ein stück weit auch als unseren
alltag wieder erleben
gucken wir nochmal in die vergangene
woche und auf den heutigen tag
während sie in deutschland noch gesellig
in der sonne saßen transportierten sie
in italien die leichen bereits mit
militärtransportern ab dass corona virus
hat italiens gesundheitssystem in die
knie gezwungen
hunderte sterben jeden tag also wurden
auch in deutschland die warnungen
unmissverständlich es geht um leben und
tod so einfach ist das und auch so
schlimm der appell bleibt zu hause
vermeidet ansteckungen verhindert
zustände wie in italien
viele erkannten den ernst der lage doch
längst nicht alle die gerne draußen und
den trinken nieder ihren pisten scheiß
aperol spritz habt ihr ne macke oder
bleibt zu hause
wenn wir zu hause bleiben können bleiben
wir zu hause wir gehen nicht vor die tür
ich komme aus zb da ist es auch wir
bleiben zu hause bringen den kindern mal
ordentlich zu reden ja
[Musik]
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
zog als erster die notbremse seit
samstag gelten strenge ausgangs
beschränkungen dann bayern nicht zu
ersparen bayern nicht ein
aber wir fahren das öffentliche leben in
bayern nahezu vollständig herunter das
vorpreschen der einen verärgert die
anderen
wir hatten ganz klar verabredet auch zum
schutz und zur nachvollziehbarkeit von
bevölkerung dass wir gemeinsam versuchen
in deutschland einen einheitlichen weg
zu gehen laut geworden soll es sein
heute auf einer telefonkonferenz der
länderchefs mit der bundeskanzlerin
im ergebnis stehen einschränkungen wie
es sie in deutschland noch nie gegeben
hat kontaktverbot bewegungs verbot
restaurants geschlossen niemand von uns
die wir in der demokratie politische
verantwortung tragen hat sich gewünscht
je mit solchen regelung vor die bürger
treten zu müssen
ich sage aber auch dies sind nicht
einfach irgendwelche empfehlungen des
staates es sind regeln
armin laschet bund und länder hatten am
donnerstag verabredet dass man heute
entscheidet einzelne länder sind
vorgeprescht bayern baden württemberg
das saarland auch rheinland-pfalz musste
das so sein und wie laut ist es heute
geworden
das ist nicht laut geworden es ist
engagiert diskutiert worden und ich
finde dass es in einer solchen lage wohl
auch unterschiedliche ansätze da sind
auch verständlich dass da auch
leidenschaft dabei ist dass der
engagement bei ist jeder kämpft für
seine idee aber am ende war entscheidend
dass man zu einer gemeinsamen position
kommt die bundesregierung und die 16
ministerpräsidenten und das ist gelungen
aber wenn das nur daher plätschern würde
und keiner sicht da engagieren würde das
wäre auch der situation unangemessen und
da gibt es auch schon mal unterschiede
und ja klar na ja sie sind könnten auch
argumentieren sie sind auch ein hotspot
sie sind auch ein grenzland also auch
sie hätten am freitag schon vor die
mikrofone treten ja ja wir haben es
jetzt heute besprochen es war für heute
verabredet und das ist jetzt in ordnung
am heutigen tag
gibt es jetzt das ergebnis das ist das
wichtigste olaf scholz ist das jetzt ein
vorpreschen ein überbietungswettbewerb
der krisenmanager oder sagen sie es gab
wirklich gute gründe für einzelne länder
da schon früher maßnahmen zwei grad
wende diese situation sollte man sich
nicht erheben und irgend jemandem
vorwürfe machen weil er entscheidung
trifft das müssen wir jetzt sowieso
jeden tag habe ich mit vielen
unsicherheiten denn keiner von uns kann
ganz genau wissen was denn nun das
richtige ist wir können uns das nur
miteinander zusammen mit experten
experten erarbeiten
aber dann müssen wir den mut haben die
richtige entscheidung zu treffen
ich glaube dass es gut ist dass in dem
gespräch das wir hatten als
bundesregierung mit den ländern heute
dieses ergebnis raus gekommen ist haben
mehr laschet und ich ja auch schon
dargestellt dass er dabei ein stimmt die
überzeugen haben so ist es auch richtig
ausgestaltet sein einsatz es ist
manchmal auch gut auch mal ein paar
stunden nachzudenken
und wir greifen seit wochen massiv in
grundrechte die bewegungsfreiheit die
gewerbefreiheit die religionsfreiheit
und die es abzuwägen und immer
zielgerichtet und verhältnismäßig zu
machen
das lohnt ein paar gedanken einmal mehr
entscheidend ist am ende dass die bürger
sehen in ganz deutschland haben wir das
gleiche ziel und arbeiten zusammen und
das ist heute bringen ich habe vor einer
stunde mit dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten markus söder kurz
sprechen können
warum konnten sie die zwei tage bis zur
heutigen sitzung nicht warten zwei tage
während zwei tage verschenkt gewesen
wir sind einen grenzgebiet unmittelbar
von österreich und italien betroffen
wir haben sehr hohe zahl von infektionen
leider auch von toten
und wenn man sieht wie wenig die appelle
auch gewirkt haben die gemacht wurden
von der großartigen geräte der kanzlerin
aber auch von mir im landtag bei
winfried kretschmann war es ähnlich
mussten wir handeln viele
kommunalpolitiker haben uns gedrängt
geschäfts der uniklinik waren bei mir
ein unzählige mails von bürgern
man muss manchmal hat man muss die
unvernünftigen zum glück auch zwingend
deswegen war es einfach notwendig zu
entscheiden ich bin auch gezwungen
deswegen weil es hier in der sache der
länder ist und jeder tag den man zögert
ist ein tag zu viel
im moment immer derjenige politiker
recht der am schnellsten und am
konsequentesten es ja das ist der
falsche maßstab ich wundere mich dass
man über die einschätzung schauen sie es
geht hier wirklich um leben und tod
da geht es nicht um stil noten die
voerder haltungsnoten die vergeben
werden von bonitäten sich absondern
können mit den anderen kollegen und wir
haben jetzt ja mehrfach gesagt schauen
sie wir haben vor über einer woche als
es darum ging es bei den
schulschliessungen waren bayern und
saarland haben die anderen ein stück
weit auch angeschoben
das ist ja auch nicht schlimm ist wir
waren die ersten die gesagt haben muss
schulen schließen alle haben gefolgt
obwohl sie einen tag zuvor eine andere
mal nach wenn sie anschauen dass am tag
nach dem wir die entscheidung getroffen
wer sogar am tag noch selbst haben
etliche bundesländer fast genau das
gleiche beschlossen oder ähnliches
beschlossen und der heutige tag zeigt
auch dass vieles von dem was wir ein
stück weit auch mit ausgearbeitet haben
jetzt von allen anderen übernommen
werden
das heißt ein bisschen ist das
vielleicht auch so dass wir beide
besonders betroffen sind und weil wir
sehen was die nachbarn um uns herum
machen wir sind ja nicht allein auf der
welt wenn selbst kalifornien oder oder
oder oder new york die fackel der
freiheit so das beschließen
er kann es ja wohl nicht sein dass
deutschland haben sonderweg machen kann
und was ist nun eigentlich der
substanzielle unterschied zwischen dem
was die bayern machen und nun alle
anderen bundesländer machen
der hauptunterschied ist wahrscheinlich
dass wir klarer sagen 'bitte eher zu
hause bleiben außer man muss zur arbeit
zur versorgung gehen beispielsweise oder
zum arzt oder um anderen zu helfen das
ist glaube ich der grundlegende
unterschied in der einige andere länder
sich noch etwas schwer tun mir gefällt
das wort kontaktsperre nicht so ganz
weil es suggeriert etwas anderes wir
haben ausgangs beschränkung was im
grunde genommen eine sagt bitte bleibt
wenn es nicht anders geht er zu hause
natürlich kann man mal zum
spazierengehen zum joggen gehen aber man
darf den leuten keine falsche keine
falsche hoffnung machen es ist die
schwerste zeit unser land derzeit hat
wenn sie die zahl der toten anschauen in
anderen ländern auch bei uns dann ist
wirklich das ist wirklich kein spaß oder
keine möglichkeit es auf die leichte
schulter zu nehmen das muss man ganz
ganz ernst nehmen
nun will in der kommenden woche auch der
bund mehr kompetenzen an sich binden mit
einer diskussion um die neuauflage des
infektionsschutzgesetzes werden sie
wird bayern da im bundesrat zustimmen ja
das sind sehr sehr viele coole sachen
drin die jens spahn ausgabe der macht
ohnehin mein mann noch eine sehr gute
figur in schwieriger zeit
er kämpft täglich um die materialien die
nach deutschland gebracht werden müssen
wenn es um schutzmasken geht atemgeräte
da sind wir in einem globalen wettbewerb
mit unmöglichen verhaltensweisen
bestimmter länder wenn es um zoll- und
beschlagnahmen ein vorauswahl geht das
nur am rande
und das gesetz das jetzt vorgelegt wird
hat sehr sehr viel gutes und ich glaube
es auch notwendig dass in so einem fall
eigentlich der einheitlichkeit
beispielsweise auch bei der ausrichtung
der ärzte besteht also wie der freistaat
bayern wären dies unterstützen markus
söder danke für das gespräch
armin laschet zu diesem eilverfahren
infektionsschutzgesetz sind auch sie
bereit ist auch nordrhein westfalen
bereit ein stück seiner macht da an den
bund abzugeben
da gibt es noch gesprächsbedarf weil die
kernfrage am ende ist wohl lassen sich
probleme besser lösen
und da hat jens spahn zugesagt dass er
das mit den gesundheitsministern jetzt
noch in dieser woche bespricht und
nochmal zur kontakt wäre also der
begriff gefällt eben nicht es gibt
ausgangs beschränkungen aber sie haben
jetzt hinlänglich erklärt was mit dem
wort kontaktsperre eigentlich gemeint
ist das ist auch nicht das ist in
ordnung das kann man so oder so
vertreten
der kern ist ich sage man soll die
wohnung verlassen um luft zu schnappen
um die kinder mal nach draußen zu
bringen
um konflikte auch die in wohnungen
entstehen können wenn menschen über tage
nicht hinausgehen das will ich ermutigen
aber ich will dazu sagen bitte passt auf
mit dem abstand und den kontakten und
die argumentation ist eine leicht andere
im ergebnis wird am ende in köln und in
münchen gleichermaßen hat das verhalten
der menschen sein und das ist ja das
entscheiden
frank ulrich montgomery wichtige frage
ist natürlich bringen kontakt sperren
bringen die medizinisch etwas wissen wir
das eigentlich es gibt einen riesen
bündel an maßnahmen kann man hat schon
mal jemand verifiziert was jetzt eine
zusätzliche kontaktsperre verbringen
kannst ja darüber gibt es keine
randomisierten prospektiven studien das
ist unmöglich
aber wir wissen das
in abhängigkeit von der inkubationszeit
natürlich die sogenannte replikas rate
ich nutze man einfach ein begriff also
die die infektionsrate für andere sinkt
gibt sehr schöne studien die beweisen
wenn es uns gelingt diese rr rate auf
1,25 zu reduzieren momentan ist sie etwa
zweimal spricht ein kranker steckst
reinhard andere an
wenn wir das auf 1,25 reduzieren dann
verlängern wir zwar insgesamt den
krankheitsverlauf in deutschland aber
wir bleiben unterhalb der
kapazitätsgrenze unserer krankenhäuser
das macht sinn und das hat man auch in
anderen ländern schon bewiesen dass das
geht also da hätte ich jetzt keine
wissenschaftlichen bedenken und so
heftig kritisiert haben sie die
italienische variante weil sie sagen
eine harte ausgangssperre bringt in
dieser jetzigen situation nur
überschaubar etwas also die wo die
italienische wie die französische
situation auch die spanischer deutlich
gezeigt dass die harte ausgangssperre
nichts bringt sie bringt nur probleme
weil sie müssen erstens sagen was machen
sie mit denen die sie brechen schicken
sie jetzt die polizei der den er zu
halten sie kommen sie aus der
ausgangssperre rational vernünftig
begründet wieder heraus und drittens
befürchte ich so etwas ich glaube da
kann frau lücken wir dazu sagen wie
einen lagerkoller in die leute zu lange
eingesperrt sind wir müssen auch das
berücksichtigen und viertens sowas gibt
auch doch deutlich radikaleren menschen
unserer gesellschaft aufschub die wollen
euch da einsperren wir bieten euch so
sei deswegen stehe ich auf vier gründen
ist gut begründet sperren zu machen aber
keine ausgangssperren olaf scholz
politiker sagen immer man muss die
menschen mitnehmen
herr laschet aktion angesprochen wie
verkauft man nie verkauft man maßnahmen
die so sehr in die freiheitsrechte der
menschen eingreifen
sie sind jurist da gibt es gar nicht zu
verkaufen so das geht hier um
ernsthaftigkeit um klarheit und
transparenz alles muss offen
angesprochen werden
das was wir wissen dass wir nicht wissen
und jeder muss nachvollziehen können
warum wir unsere entscheidungen treffen
aber gleichzeitig auch immer das gefühl
haben dass wir alle zusammen halten
ich habe den eindruck dass das was du
als
wann man ja auch ein bisschen
merkwürdiger streit zwischen parteien
stattfinden gegenwärtig sehr reduziert
ist
natürlich sind wir im demokratischen
wettbewerb aber hier ist doch eine ganz
große herausforderung der menschheit und
unseres landes bei der wir viel mehr als
sonst zusammen arbeiten müssen und
manchmal hoffe ich dass das jetzt auch
nach der krise noch was für uns mit sich
bringt aber jetzt in dieser situation
gibt es nur offenheit nur klarheit und
nur erklären und entschieden dass sie
sind staatsrechtler herr lasse
befürchten sie dass menschen auch
dagegen klagen das ist bisher nicht
erkennbar aber so einklagen kann immer
jemand glaube es ist staatsrechtlich
verfassungsrechtlich alles in ordnung
was gemacht wird und das was der scholz
sagt stimmt im bundestag und auch bei
uns im landtag eine atmosphäre wo auch
die oppositionsparteien zustimmen wo in
erster zweiter dritter lesung an einem
tag entschieden wird das gibt's nie im
normalen parlamentarischen ablaufen
bundestag und bundesrat innerhalb von 24
stunden zusammen entscheiden
das ist ein zusammenhalt der weit über
parteigrenzen hinweg geht und ich glaube
dass das was wir machen alles
verfassungsrechtlich in ordnung ist und
man muss es trotzdem immer auch mal
daraufhin prüfen und sich immer auch
sagen
man wird in ein paar monaten sehen was
habt ihr eigentlich in der krise gemacht
wie habt ihr agiert und da ist die
grundsätze der verfassung mit zu
beachten immer ein maßstab auch in der
zukunft
nun gibt es menschen im land die lassen
unsinn nur dann sein wenn er explizit
verboten ist das heißt eine mehrheit
richtet sich jetzt nach meiner minder
hat nein die große mehrheit hält sich an
die regeln
die unvernünftige als wehrheimer
ungestraft nein die unvernünftigen die
vernünftigen halten sich an die regeln
das kann man überall feststellen aber
die wenigen unvernünftigen werden ab
morgen starke sanktionen spüren
und man muss dann auch mal sehr schnell
morgen übermorgen es auch öffentlich
machen wie man durchgegriffen hat damit
es eine abschreckung für all die anderen
ist und das ist übrigens zu deren schutz
ich habe am wochenende zusammen gesessen
mit
der notfall medizin und intensivmedizin
der rwth aachen des uniklinikums
die haben mir gesagt da läge nicht nur
ältere es gibt auch jüngere inzwischen
und deshalb können die jünger nicht
sagen das ist nicht unser problem
es geht jeden an und das ist jetzt auch
zu deren schutz durchzusetzen
vielleicht noch mal die frage an frau
lücken der plan an die vernunft zu
appellieren und zu bitten
der ist dann also gescheitert ich würde
nicht sagen jetzt der gescheitert ist
denn ich denke dass bei vielen hat genau
dieser appell auch gewirkt aber menschen
unterscheiden sich menschen
unterscheiden sich auch in der art und
weise wie sie solche veränderungen
verarbeiten wir kennen das gerade auch
aus der erforschung von schweren
erkrankungen wenn sie zum beispiel eine
krebsdiagnose bekommen kommt es häufig
dazu dass im ersten stadium erstmal
leugnen dass überhaupt eine solche
diagnose stattgefunden hat und genauso
wird geleugnet die ernsthaftigkeit der
situation aber am ende des tages stoßen
sie sich doch in der realität den kopf
und das passiert jetzt und dadurch kann
aber auch dann die verarbeitung und
damit auch der umgang mit der situation
eingeleitet werden herr montgomery die
gesunden sollen zu hause bleiben die
infizierten und die kranken müssen zu
hause bleiben können das ganz praktische
frage die gesundheitsämter eigentlich
kontrollieren
also das ist keine frage der
gesundheitsämter die sind leider in den
letzten jahren von den kommunen so
heruntergewirtschaftet worden dass die
das niemals schaffen würden darum geht
es nicht
ich bin bei frau lücken wir müssen bei
den menschen selber dass die einsicht
erzeugen wird da sind wir auf einem
guten weg da habe ich gar nicht das
problem also vor allem dürfen nicht
vergessen viele von denen die krank sind
sind ja nur sehr leicht krank und die
anderen die schwer krank sind werden im
krankenhaus sein das heißt hier sehe ich
nicht das große problem dass die nun
rumlaufen und alle infizieren viel
problematischer ist nach wie vor die
besorgung von schutzmaßnahmen wohl für
die die infiziert sind wie auch für die
die diese menschen entgegennehmen in den
krankenhäusern die sie behandeln
aber hier ist der bund ebenfalls dabei
nachzubessern
aber irgendwann bereuen sie noch mal
ganz in rot gesundheitsämter und ihr
haus bluten und über föderale strukturen
zum beispiel beim robert koch-institut
reden dass wir zb bei
allen zahlen uns auf eine amerikanische
universität verlassen und das haben wir
koch-institut zwei tage hinterher hinkt
ist eigentlich eine peinlichkeit für ein
solch gutes land so gut entwickeltes
land und auch für das robert koch
institut die nichts dafür können
ich wäre sehr froh wenn wir in zukunft
hier mal den zwischen weg über die
landesbehörden der länder ausschalten
könnten und direkt meldungen der fälle
ans lka machen können da wird zwar dann
ein bisschen föderal aufgegeben aber das
wäre ein sinnvoller ansatz damit wir
endlich über eigene gute statistiken
verfügen das wäre nicht schlecht
momentan orientieren wir uns noch an den
zahlen der johns-hopkins-universität
frau lücken noch einmal zu der situation
der menschen niemand ist eine insel sagt
man so schön
die frage ist natürlich wie halten wir
diese kontakt armut aus oder das
alleinsein aus hilft uns da tatsächlich
diese digitale welt aus unserer kontakt
not also zunächst einmal glaube ich wir
so nicht von social sondern von physical
systems inc sprechen wir müssen uns
nicht sozial ist verändern darf
distanzieren und genau das ist glaube
ich auch die chance dass wir über
soziale medien verfügen die wir jetzt in
einem sehr starken ausmaß einsetzen
können um ebendiese face to face
kontakte zu ersetzen
denken sie an menschen die besonders
isoliert sind die jetzt besonders viel
kontakt brauchen führen sie regelmäßig
telefon meetings ein
und ich glaube darüber kann viel
sozialer kontakt auch kompensiert werden
und ich glaube dieses gefühl auch von
zusammengehörigkeit was gerade wieder
neu erwächst ist ein sehr gutes
gegenmittel auch gegen angst und
einsamkeit die ohren glühen und sozial
ist digital
ihr habt gesundheitsämter auch bei
meinem kollegen johannes b kerner schon
angerufen haben können wir ihnen gleich
fragen
er ist uns zugeschaltet aus hamburg und
hat jetzt schon das gros der zeit seiner
quarantäne überstanden guten abend
johannes wie geht es die erste frage
vielen herzlichen dank der nachfrage bei
britt ich bin sehr dankbar dass du mir
einen äußeren anlass gegeben hat dass
ich mal aus der jogginghose rauskommen
es geht mir sehr gut ich habe insgesamt
einen sehr flachen verlauf gehabt und
das ist im unteren auch der grund warum
ich teilnehmer an dieser sendung um
zu versuchen den menschen ein bisschen
sorge zu nehmen natürlich kann ich nur
individuell über das sprechen was ich
erlebt habe und wie es mir ergangen ist
und geht
das ist also eine rein persönliche
geschichte aber wir lesen immer die zahl
dass vier von fünf verletzten eher flach
sind und konzentrieren uns doch mit der
sorgen mit der angst über haben in der
hauptsache auch die todeszahlen und das
so ein bisschen zu entfernen vielleicht
kann ich mithelfen das heißt nicht dass
ich verharmlosen möchte was menschen
schweres erleben willst du nicht
misszuverstehen und das kann auch
überhaupt nicht missverstanden werden
bei der übergroßen mehrzahl du hast das
schon erwähnt der menschen gibt es eben
diesen schwachen verlauf oder einen sehr
leichten verlauf und das war bei dir
auch so kann ich ganz genau sagen heute
vor 14 tagen hatte ich kam aus amerika
zurück hatte ich zum ersten mal machen
nennen was ein leichtes kratzen im hals
und ich fühlte mich so ein bisschen müde
das schiebt man dann auch ein jetlag
weil man ja auch ein flugzeug nicht so
gut schlägt dann ging das nicht so
richtig weg und dann wurden die symptome
mehr dann aber immer noch total flach
also immer noch so dass ich eigentlich
immer überlegt haben gehe ich noch
joggen oder gehe ich nicht und habe mich
aber dann noch vermehrt dagegen
entschieden dann habe ich so nachgedacht
wo ich überall war ein letzter zeit in
südtirol im januar und in tirol im
februar zweimal und an weichen das für
eine sendung und dann war ich in miami
und in new york
das hast du auf einmal ich auch schon
ganz schön viel unterwegs in den letzten
wochen und dann hörte ich dass das
ehepaar was unter mir wohnt er in
hamburg dass die beiden positiv getestet
sind und wir den fahrstuhl gemeinsam
benutzten türklinken gemeinsam benutzen
und dann habe ich einen arzt um rat
gebeten
ist das jetzt eine gemengelage die im
test sinnvoll macht und dann hat er
gesagt ja das so der für denkbar halten
haben den test gemacht eigentlich uns
auszuschließen und wann dann ganz
überrascht vom ergebnis und ich habe
mich dann natürlich unmittelbar in diese
sogenannte häusliche isolation abend
lief im zdf deine sendung der quest
champion zum glück eine aufzeichnung
wie war es dir beim warmmachen
zuzugucken
ehrlich gesagt guck mal eine eigene
sendung nicht so aber tatsächlich erst
ein paar minuten reingeguckt ja das ist
bei aufgezeichneten sendungen ja nicht
unüblich ich hatte was meinen job angeht
das glück dass tatsächlich glaubt 22
tage vor dem ersten
symptomen die letzte aufzeichnung waren
dass meine nächste erst in einigen
wochen ist so dass ich die krankheit
sozusagen ganz gut da rein geparkt habe
ja ich habe halt gemerkt dass die
menschen sorge haben und nun vielleicht
kann ich auf diese art und weise einigen
menschen ein bisschen sorge nehmen habe
es bei instagram mehr öffentlich gemacht
und da habe ich nicht mal ein fachleuten
angeschrieben und angesprochen ob es
nicht möglich wäre dass ich in einer
form von tagebuch berichte bisher geht
sind natürlich dann noch so zwei drei
sachen dazu gekommen im laufe der
letzten 14 tage aber die sind noch
wieder wecken haben dich denn
mittlerweile nur um das auch zu fragen
ärzte oder gesundheitsämter angerufen
bist du da in dem kontakt ja also in dem
moment wo der test gemacht wird und
positiv ist ist man in einem verfahren
in einer prozedur das ist bei mir das in
hamburg-nord dass das gesundheitsamt die
haben mich dann kontaktiert und habe mir
mit ein bisschen verzögerungen aber die
sind natürlich total überlastet jetzt
habe ich jedes verständnis
die quarantäne ausgesprochen erst
fernmündlich also telefon und dann habe
ich das auch per mail schriftlich
bekommen also ist richtig eine amtliche
anordnung und ich musste dann eine
fieber verlauf festhalten morgens und
abends temperatur messen und musste in
so einer excel tabelle eintragen ob es
symptome gibt ja oder nein in welchem
ausmaß usw
und heute mittag habe ich dann nach dem
14 am vierten tag der ersten symptome
die liste ausgefüllt zurückgeschickt und
am heutigen abend habe ich dann eine
mail bekommen am späten nachmittag dass
die quarantäne zu morgen aufgehoben ist
das heißt ich kann mich dann morgen in
dem maße wie wir alle dass nur können
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt auch draußen
wieder an die front werfen wichtig
natürlich zu fragen wie wie hast du das
wär hat deine familie das ausgehalten
das habt ihr in der zeit gemacht ja also
ich lebe hier in dieser wohnung lebe ich
allein weil ich ja von der mutter meiner
kinder getrennt bin und aber natürlich
die kontakte verstehen uns gut und gehen
prima miteinander um
bin ich ja allein gewesen und ich kann
nur das was folgen eben gesagt hat
wirklich unterstreichen das ist etwas
was man irgendwann körperlich spüren die
die sozialkontakte oder wie ich jetzt
gelernt habe die physischen kontakte
kann man nicht digitalisieren das ist
etwas an
da kannst du video calls machen so
vielen winzigen das ist etwas anderes
und auch ich habe als das jetzt hoffe
das ist nicht zu privat als mein sohn
mir was zu essen gebracht hat und er auf
zwei meter entfernung oder drei meter
auf dem treppenabsatz stand auch das
wirklich das gefühl gehabt hätten sich
das bedürfnis ihn zum abend trauriger
moment und ich kann mir vorstellen dass
menschen die insgesamt nicht so stabil
sind dass die darunter wirklich leiden
da sollten wir sehr vorsichtig bildung
gehen an welcher situation an welcher
hoffnung hast du dich festgehalten
danach immun zu sein ja das ist
natürlich immer das zu sagen friede du
bist dann nach der gesündeste deutsche
und so weiter das sind dann so sprüche
geklopft werden
der verlauf ist ja so uns das ergebnis
dann im ersten mal bist du wie ein
bisschen schockiert das ist nach ein
paar sekunden weg dann hast du angst
dann fragst du deine erste was ist jetzt
zu tun muss ich jetzt meine
angelegenheiten regeln oder was ist zu
tun dann hatten einen arzt
die beiden ärzte mit denen ich
gesprochen haben mich sehr berührt sagt
aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach flachau
verlauf gesunder an und so weiter keine
vorerkrankungen und dann kommt sozusagen
die zuversicht tag für tag dazu weil du
merkst dass fieber kommt nicht an einem
tag kann ich vielleicht auch noch sagen
da hatte ich morgens ein bisschen heißen
schädel und da habe ich mich gar nicht
getraut fieber zu messen und habe dann
nach einer halben stunde allen mut
zusammen genommen
man hat mich glaube ich 36 2 sowas gibt
es auch und dann macht man sich halt
total verrückt und das ist nicht der
richtige weg
die angst die sorge ist ein total blöde
begleiter aber mit jedem tag ist dann
eben besser und was war deine größte
sorge nach der hoffnung habe ich mich
schon gefragt was war die größte sorge
war natürlich dass der krankheitsverlauf
sich intensiviert das was dazu kommt
woran man jetzt noch nicht denken dass
dann doch irgend ein druckgefühl auf der
lunge und all diese sachen die man eher
die man ja beschreibt oder die man über
die man lesen kann klar wie ich auch die
fernsehsendung verfolgt und habe zeitung
gelesen und dass das ist einfach die
sorge dass das dann irgendwann
ausspricht ich habe im verlaufe der zeit
eine nebenwirkung festgestellt eine
nebenwirkung gesagt man also einen
symptome festgestellt dass der prophet
der biologe der professor aus bordeaux
geschrieben hat als er die heinsberger
patienten gesehen hat
die beeinträchtigung des geruchs und
geschmacks sind das war bei mir auch so
ist aber noch drei tage
johannes vielen vielen dank dass wir mit
dir reden konnten
keep on rocking würde ich mal sagen
danke für dieses gespräch und ich möchte
vielleicht darf ich lass mich die
gelegenheit mein bild nur die zehn
sekunden einfach wirklich noch mal auch
ich möchte alle aufrufen die regeln die
die heute festgelegt worden sind
einzuhalten
ich möchte den pflegekräften banken die
machen einen unglaublichen job und
vielleicht können wir nach dieser
geschichte irgendwas mit rausnehmen aus
dieser wirklich großen krisenhaften
situation irgendwas was die gesellschaft
positiv verändert was den zusammenhalt
stärkt und wir einfach miteinander
umgehen ich habe gute hoffnung dass uns
das so sehr bewegt das ist nachhaltige
wochen hat vielen dank
unbedingt mehr sehen nach hamburg
vorliegen und damit sind wir bei der
frage welche hilfestellung sie geben
können was kann eine psychologin sagen
womit kommt man über diese zeit ja also
es ist eine sehr herausfordernde
situation wenn sie in häuslicher
isolation oder sogar quarantäne leben
müssen und ich würde gerne einfach ein
paar ganz konkrete hilfen mit an die
hand geben die ein bisschen unterstützen
können das erstes dass man sich eine
tagesstruktur geben muss ja wenn die
externen taktgeber wegfallen gerät man
den gefahren so ein loch zu fallen das
heißt machen sie die dinge die sie sonst
auch immer machen gehen sie schlafen zu
der zeit wo sie schlafen gehen und
machen sie sich vor allen dingen am
abend feuer mit ihrer familie zusammen
einen plan den stundenplan für den
nächsten tag und bauen sie auch
highlights ein schöner aktivitäten an
denen sie sich erfreuen können
das zweite was sehr wichtig ist wir
hatten es gerade schon angesprochen
halten sie pflegen sie soziale kontakte
auf distanz das kann nicht den
körperlichen kontakt ersetzen aber es
kann es ein stück weit kompensieren
der dritte punkt ist der konsumieren sie
informationen und medien mit bedacht ja
wir tendieren immer dazu unsere
unsicherheit zu reduzieren indem wir
ganz viel im internet suchen sondern das
gegenteil dies oft der fall ich würde
empfehlen auch hier nach plan zu handeln
nicht nach gefühl das heißt geben sie
sich zeiten morgens eine halbe stunde am
halbe stunde wo sie sich informieren
greifen sie auf etablierte medien zurück
damit sie nicht gefahr laufen
mit fake news versorgt zu werden und ein
weiterer wichtiger punkt mit dem leute
oft zu uns kommen ist was mache ich
gegen diese grübel schleifen ja auch da
manche menschen denken je mehr ich etwas
über etwas nachdenken desto besser löse
sich das problem das ist aber oft nicht
der fall
ja das heißt auch hier zeiten einrichten
sich zehn minuten geben am tag morgens
und abends sich vielleicht auch ein
wecker stellen wo sie grübeln dürfen und
dann was anderes machen
körperliche betätigung mit den kindern
spielen und last but not least wenn sie
mal eine entspannungs oder achtsamkeit
technik gelernt haben wäre es zeigt
jetzt die zeit dass wieder zu
reaktivieren es gibt auch viele
hilfreiche apps die ihnen das in ganz
einfachen schritten beibringen und auch
das kann helfen gegen solche grübel
schleifen und sich den stress damit auch
auszüge aus der seele die neue tonne ein
wenig abschöpfen
die wassertonne abschließend auf sowas
habe ich gewartet heute familien
partnerschaften ihre wohngemeinschaften
auch die sind natürlich in einem
seelischen ausnahmezustand kann man in
einer solchen zeit verlegen konflikte
einfrieren
also zunächst einmal finde ich es ganz
wichtig zu betonen neben den
körperlichen risikogruppen werden wir
durch die veränderungen in unserem
alltag jetzt auch psychische
risikogruppen bekommen
menschen mit psychischen erkrankungen
die jetzt nicht mehr optimal versorgt
werden können alleinerziehende eltern
die den druck ganz alleine tragen
genauso wie familien die in beengten
prekären verhältnissen leben
das heißt also diesen menschen müssen
wir identifizieren wir müssen angebote
formulieren ja wir haben eine liste
zusammengestellt die wahrscheinlich auch
hier online abrufbar ist wo wir ganz
konkrete hilfen formulieren wie man mit
solchen konfliktsituationen umgehen kann
wie man das auch entfernen kann
wichtig glaube ich ist dass sie sich je
dass sich jeder auch ein wenig raum für
sich selber lässt dass man nicht immer
nur aufeinander setzt sondern sich
bewusst auszeiten für sich alleine
suchen
das finden sie auf den link zu unserer
sendung armin laschet logische frage es
ist natürlich etwas anderes ob ich in
einem haus mit einem garten wohne oder
aber in einer zweizimmerwohnung also
klassisch der konflikt stadt land ist es
tatsächlich
ist dem virus ja egal aber dem bewohner
natürlich nicht egal wo man zu hause ist
lässt sich das lösen
also ich fand es gerade eine wirklich
fantastische beschreibung die auch im
normalen leben vielleicht hilfe sein
könnte wenn man das so an wenig mal
strukturiert ja in der tat je enger die
wohnung ist in der man lebt in den
großen städten oft menschen in zwei drei
zimmer wohnungen mit mehreren kindern
das ist was anderes wenn sie draußen auf
dem land wohnen und ein garten da ist
und man da hinauskam
deshalb ist mir dieser wohnungsfrage ja
auch so wichtig er hat der
kinderschutzbund gesagt wir haben sorge
um das kindeswohl in vielen städten
frauenverbände sagen wir haben angst vor
häuslicher gewalt wir wissen über die
weihnachtstage wenn menschen 34 tage
plötzlich zusammen sind dass es viele
polizeieinsätze gibt weil es zu
konflikten kommt und der teil ist jetzt
nicht unbedingt mit einem virus
verbunden aber ist natürlich für die
gesellschaft auch für gesundheitsfragen
eine ganz relevanten und nochmal frage
an den vizekanzler stichwort häusliche
gewalt kann man da über notprogramme
nachdenken kann man bei menschen die so
gut wie keine sozialen kontakte haben
gleichermaßen strukturiert hilfen und
programme anbieten
das kann man ich bin auch überzeugt dass
das über in deutschland jetzt geschieht
dass die länder das die
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister der
städte und gemeinden jetzt mit den
sozialen dienst mit den ehrenamtlichen
darüber nachdenken was da möglich ist
und ich glaube dass wir auch alle
möglichkeiten haben bestimmte dinge zu
nutzen die jetzt ein neuer kapazität
entstehen
denn ja auch die einrichtung wie zb
sozialen bereich tätig sind haben
plötzlich ja keine besucher mehr
und wenn die mitarbeiter und mitarbeiter
mit der gemeinde mit dem land
verständigung treffen können wie sie das
was sie an zeit haben jetzt nutzen
können um zum beispiel solche
unterstützung zu leisten wenn wir das
sehr gut wir haben uns jetzt auch gerade
darauf verständigt dass wir zum beispiel
mit hilfe der sozialversicherung
sicherstellen wollen dass die
einrichtung die vereine die unternehmen
die bisher von diesen sozialversicherung
bezahlt etwas für bürgern und bürgertum
die zeit auch nutzen um zum beispiel in
diesem bereich mit tätig sein zu können
aber wir dadurch ihre finanzierung auch
gewährleisten also da gibt es viele
möglichkeiten die uns jetzt alle genutzt
werden herr montgomery menschen unter
stress zu setzen und auf engstem raum
einzusperren das hat und unterhaltungs
gesichtspunkten big brother zuletzt
erfunden was bedeutet eine solche
situation aber für ein ganzes land mit
welchen nebenwirkungen muss man da
rechnen
die nebenwirkungen sind im ansatz eben
schon von produkten beschrieben wurden
mir geht es jetzt eigentlich vor allem
darum dass wir diese ganzen maßnahmen ja
machen und die schwächsten unserer
gesellschaft zu schützen auch indem wir
ihnen sagen bleibt zu hause
jetzt dürfen sie aber nicht zu hause
vergessen sondern wir müssen gerade den
schwächsten der gesellschaft also nicht
der familie die einigermaßen intakt ist
da kann das ja auch passieren aber die
brauchen nicht so viel hilfe weil die
armen alten menschen die alleine zu
hause sitzen oder aber die einen kranken
partner zu hause versorgen und die
müssen wir uns jetzt mehr kümmern und
das bedarf als einsatzes vieler menschen
die ehre sehr motiviert sind und bei
denen wir dann auch klarmachen müssen
das kontaktverbot gilt dann nicht wenn
du mit einem schutzkittel mit
entsprechender ausbildung mit
entsprechender schutzmaßnahme für dich
selber sich auch um solche menschen dann
kümmert fragen wir gleich armin laschet
noch mal wichtige frage auch für viele
unserer zuschauer bahn wird es diesen
test geben diesen anti gen test mit dem
wir bestätigen können eben die
antikörper zu haben und immun zu sein
und also wieder raus zu können das ist
eine gemeine frage weil das kann ich
ihnen so ohne weiteres und es gibt
ansätze diese tests haben bisher eine zu
geringe spezifität weil sie allgemein
gegen korona wäre noch nicht gegen
dieses berühmte saß koch 2 wirken da
muss man wirklich in die labore gucken
wann die spezifität so ist das hier auch
vernünftige werte messen ich habe auch
hört was von mai juni dann wissen wir
auch welche menschen wahrscheinlich auf
lange zeit immun sind die könnte man
dann natürlich besser einsetzen auch in
der betreuung derjenigen die das noch
vor sich haben genau die in schutz der
schwächsten ist angesprochen worden
armin laschet wie organisiert man jetzt
dass aldi
menschen die in pflegeheimen leben das
sind ja auch 800.000 knappe million über
700.000 beschäftigte dass die
tatsächlich auch entsprechende hilfe
bekommen denn auch die leiden unter
kontakt armut man darf sie nicht mehr
besucht
das ist ja wirklich ernste frage die
einem zum teil auch das herz bricht also
wenn man sich vorstellt ein enger
angehöriger ist im krankenhaus und man
sagt du darfst du jetzt nicht besuchen
das geht heute in der digitalisierung
wenigstens mal optisch früher wäre gar
nicht möglich gewesen aber die
entscheidende frage ist die
pflegebedürftigen wo pfleger hingehen
die sagen natürlich wir sind ja auch
nicht geschützt wir haben keine masken
zum beispiel und jetzt muss man das
abstufen das erste ist die masken für
alle die in der klinik sind müssen jetzt
kommen der bund hilft der bund beschafft
die bundeswehr hilft im kreis heinsberg
ist heute ein transport der bundeswehr
eingetroffen
dass der erste teil aber danach wird man
das mit den masken ausdehnen müssen auf
viele die einen solchen kontakt haben
vielleicht doch irgendwann wenn es so
weitergeht auch im öffentlichen leben
stärker mal eine maske zu tragen
die nicht so sein wird wie in der klinik
aber zum beispiel der an der kasse sitzt
oder viele andere sind hier auch mit
sehr vielen menschen in einem
unmittelbaren kontakt nun man muss eins
nach dem anderen machen und die
pflegebedürftige ist die nächste gruppe
die man jetzt schon in den blick nehmen
wer wegen corona kollwitz 19 ins
krankenhaus muss frau lücken der bleibt
allein und er stirbt gegebenenfalls auch
allein gibt es psychologische betreuung
auch in den deutschen krankenhäusern ja
also die bilder die wir aus den teilen
sind sind natürlich sehr erschreckend
und ich weiß von initiativen psychologen
arbeiten hier ja auch in den kliniken
also von der onkologie bis in die
intensiv medizin und es gibt gerade
laufen jetzt initiativen das zu
organisieren
das personal zu verstärken sodass wir
psychologische unterstützung
krisenbewältigung anbieten können für
betroffene patienten für angehörige aber
auch für die pflegekräfte die unter
einem
enormen druck stehen und auch für die
bevölkerung versuchen wir gerade ein
angebot zu formulieren die deutsche
gesellschaft für psychologie baut eine
hotline auf in der wir
krisenintervention anbieten wollen
wir würden sehr gerne mit den ärztlichen
kollegen da zusammenarbeiten auch mit
der politik um eben der bevölkerung auch
ein niederschwelliges angebot zur
bewältigung anbieten zu können um auch
mit diesem stress fertig zum ländern was
man jetzt die angehörigen nicht besuchen
darf und gewinnen heute sagen den
pfleger beschimpft
hermann connery in großbritannien habe
ich gelesen denkt man jetzt darüber nach
drei monate lang über 70-jährige in
quarantäne zu bringen da sagen nicht
wenige das ist folter kann man das
machen darf man das machen also die
gedankenwelt eines boris jones
nachzuvollziehen später auch als
gebürtiger engländer relativ schwer aber
ich halte das in der tat ich was der
begriff folter richtig halte das in der
wir gerade in der tat nicht für den
richtigen ansatz weil der ja damit
gepaart wird dass alle anderen sich
jetzt möglichst schnell infizieren
sollen damit wir eine herdenimmunität in
der bevölkerung haben
das ist eine in meinen augen sehr gute
theorie und ich würde denken sie mal auf
dem papier sie funktioniert maximal auf
dem papier sie trägt ein hohes risiko
dass ihnen nämlich das gesamte
infektionsgeschehen komplett entgleitet
deswegen haben wir uns in deutschland
bewusst dagegen entschieden das ist
richtig und das ist schon wichtig
technische situation die haben das
indirekt gemacht weil die haben
wahrscheinlich vier wochen überhaupt
nicht gemerkt was in ihrem land
passieren das war dann diese situation
des ungeregelten zustroms und des
ungeregelten zuwachses von infektionen
und als es dann zu spät war haben sie
die anderen maßnahmen gemacht wir sind
übrigens dank
hier entspannen das stehe ich hier an
und der bundesregierung weit vor dieser
phase wir haben wirklich sehr früh
angefangen und die bundesregierung hat
hier wirklich sehr viele gute dinge
gemacht
ich bin wirklich nicht verdächtig die
bundesregierung und sprach sich zu loben
aber hier kann man das sagen das haben
sie gut gemacht er richtig christian
drosten sagte zuletzt in unserer sendung
wir haben mit den tests gelernt und die
italiener eben leider mit den toten
olaf scholz wie sehr wird diese krise
auch unser system auch unsere demokratie
verändern
es wird in der kommenden woche
wahrscheinlich auch einen entscheid
gegenüber möglicherweise über eine
handyortung dass infizierte infizierte
und kontaktpersonen der infizierten per
handy geortet werden oder eben auch über
drohnen geortet werden ist das was wo
sie sagen das müssen wir jetzt auch
machen oder glauben sie es ist besser
bei dieser anonymisierten überprüfung zu
bleiben die wir dann ans robert koch
robert koch-institut geben welche
möglichkeiten sich mit den handys um den
nutzer daten ergeben das versuchen wir
gerade noch herauszufinden das wird
jetzt nicht in dem gesetzespaket von
dieser woche sein aber wir haben uns
vorgenommen genau die frage was ist
sinnvoll wie weit kann man gehen wie
weit kann man nicht gehen zu diskutieren
unsere einschätzung dass was ich gelernt
habe aus vielen diskussionen ist dass
das vor allem interessantes für die
phase wenn wir allmählich alles wieder
aufmachen dann glaube ich wird es
interessant jetzt wo wir die kontakte so
weit eingeschränkt haben ist die
wirksamkeit viel geringer es geht eher
um die frage wie können wir uns
gewissermaßen an der öffnung erlauben
und haben wir dann mit den möglichkeiten
der technologie dort option in die uns
das leben vielleicht sogar leichter
machen da weiß ich noch genau die
datenschutz hat natürlich bedenken an
dem ich nicht sehe ich fand ich habe
also die entstand infektionsschutzgesetz
entwurf von gestern abend und kranken
das entlassungs sitzung gestern abend
gelesen gesagt wahrscheinlich inzwischen
schon weiter aber diesen entwurf würde
ich als arzt einfach nur sagen der ist
in ordnung da sind natürlich dinge drin
die uns nicht schmecken aber das ist
jetzt egal
machen sie das tun sie doch einfach ein
verfallsdatum drauf sagen sie in zwei
jahren überprüfen wir das so machen in
einem geregelten verfahren im bundestag
mit anhörungen von experten auch eine
analyse ob das geklappt hat und machen
sie es aber jetzt erst mal und lassen
sie vor allem nicht die gefahr aufkommen
dass das nachher im bundestag um
zwischen bundestag und bundesrat
zerredet wird
das waren allesamt in der krise
erträgliche regelungen das sollten wir
schnell machen wir nicht mehr lange
darüber diskutiert und warnen
verfassungsschützer tatsächlich auch
davor herr laschet sehen sie die gefahr
dass wir uns im grunde in die
der besonderen situation auch über
überwachung keine gedanken mehr machen
oder zu wenig machen und uns daran
gewöhnen weil wir gewöhnen uns ja an
sehr viel
naja das dürfen wir nicht deshalb muss
man genau hinschauen sagen was ist jetzt
der krise angemessen
der gedanke es mal befristet für eine
zeit zu machen die und dann aber auch
wieder wegfallen zu lassen ist auch ein
kluger gedanke und ich glaube das
hauptziel und das muss man auch glaube
ich noch mal erklären ist ja lediglich
was lediglich anspruchsvoll genug diese
kurve flacher für den zeitpunkt in zwei
drei wochen wenn potenziell der
höhepunkt erreicht ist oder vier wochen
irgendwann wird er da sein und wir sind
in deutschland das kann man vielleicht
auch noch mal zur beruhigung sagen von
der zahl der intensiv plätze auch etwas
besser vorbereitet als italien wo allein
das nach nordrhein-westfalen 18
millionen einwohnern hat mehr intensiv
plätze als ganz italien so insofern ist
die chance da dass ganz deutschland am
tag iks genügend plätze hat und deshalb
ist alles was jetzt reduziert und das
tempo rausnimmt die große chance in zwei
wochen in drei wochen besser dazustehen
als wenn man es nicht gemacht wir haben
wenn ich das kurz zu sagen dafür uns ja
auch vorgenommen obwohl es schon 28.000
intensivbetten in deutschland gibt diese
zeit sowieso zahl zu verdoppeln damit
wir möglichst viel kapazität haben
das haben wir ja auch schon gesprochen
frau lücken nicht nur unsere vernunft
wird ja auf eine probe gestellt sondern
auch unsere geduld
hält man eine solche ausnahme situation
besser aus und vielleicht nur aus wenn
man weiß wann sie zu ende ist ich glaube
die frage ist vielleicht falsch gestellt
weil korrigieren sie mit natürlich ist
es somit unsicherheit zu leben ist immer
eine herausforderung aber ich glaube
keiner von uns kann momentan mit einem
guten gewissen irgendeine zahl nennen
und wenn dann werden wir wahrscheinlich
falsch liegen
deswegen glaube ich dass es gut ist auf
sich zufahren stellen sie sich vor sie
wollen den himalaya besteigen so was
machen wir jetzt ja gerade sie gehen ja
vom basislager zu basislager
und jedes mal im basislager machen sie
eine überprüfung wie geht es mir
gesundheitlich wie ist die allgemeine
wetterlage muss ich absteigen muss ich
ein paar tage mich akklimatisieren
oder kann ich weiter aufsteigen und
genau das sehe ich auch in der politik
momentan dass wir uns adjustieren und
dass wir auf sicht fahren sodass wir
auch flexibel genug sind die maßnahmen
die ergriffen werden anzupassen ich
glaube dass wir mit dieser strategie
indem wir immer auf den nächsten schritt
schauen gut über diese situation
hinwegkommen
und trotzdem hofft man natürlich dass
die politik schon ein bisschen weiter
schaut also auf den himalaya sicherlich
auf jeden fall sonst hätten sie jetzt
nicht eine bazooka rausgeholt aber man
möchte sich natürlich vorstellen und
wünscht sich dass die bundesregierung
eben über das was wir schon sprachen
jetzt nachdenkt unter welchen kriterien
kann man wann wieder öffnen kann man
irgendwann die oberschüler vielleicht
wieder in die schulen lassen kann man
irgendwann die kindergärten vielleicht
wieder öffnen
um eben nicht sofort den riesen sprung
zu haben oder ihn zu provozieren aber
wenigstens in teilen soziales leben
wieder möglich zu machen
ich bestehe darauf dass wir uns
verabreden dass wir zuerst auf die
gesundheitliche entwicklung schauen denn
das ist ja das was wir jetzt gemeinsam
machen indem wir sagen wir riskieren
sehr viel wir fahren einen großen teil
des sozialen lebens und damit auch der
wirtschaftlichen aktivität herunter
damit wir die gesundheit unserer
bürgerinnen und bürger davon uns allen
schützen können und das darf niemals in
frage gestellt werden deshalb müssen wir
die entwicklung beobachten
zb welche auswirkungen haben umso
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben die
wir jetzt ergriffen verschaffen wochen
lang und wir müssen genau gucken wie
weit sind die medizinischen fortschritte
wie weit ist der aufbau unserer
medizinischen kapazitäten
fortgeschritten und dann können wir
stück für stück
darauf aufbauend entscheidungen treffen
und da ich ja nun als finanzminister
eine große verantwortung dafür habe dass
wir den rahmen den finanziellen rahmen
sicherstellen dass wir das ökonomisch
durch erleben dass wir die arbeitsplätze
sichern dass wir die betriebe und
unternehmen sichern dass es ein kommt
sicherheit gibt für die bürgerinnen und
bürger
zeige ich trotzdem niemals dürfen wir
falsch rum denken und sagen jetzt geht
es nur noch ums geld sondern es muss um
die frage gehen wie schützen wir die
sicherheit unserer bürger 100 das stimmt
aber trotz allem und das machen sie
jetzt nächste woche muss wissen wir
jetzt auch daran denken wenn es denn zu
ende ist wie ich sind sind unsere
unternehmen noch da sind die menschen
noch da gibt es arbeitslosigkeit und die
große gefahr ist dass wir in eine 10 15
jäger echte krise hinein rutschen und
insofern beides passiert gerade der
bundesfinanzminister und der
wirtschaftsminister legen maßnahmen vor
dass die unternehmen noch da sind wenn
die krise zu ende ist und die menschen
auch nicht entlassen sind und trotzdem
volle kraft auf die gesundheits dinge
also beides glaube ich im gleichgewicht
zu halten auch wenn wir über das thema
jetzt weniger gesprochen haben ist
trotzdem bei uns wichtig so und dann
heißt es ja nicht nur bei uns sondern es
ist auch in europa und in der welt
wichtig also eine maßnahme wie der
italienische ministerpräsident sie jetzt
getroffen hat zu sagen nur die
lebenswichtigen firmen sollen überhaupt
noch arbeiten und alle anderen firmen
machen wir zu sehen sie eine situation
wo wir auch das tun müssten derzeit
nicht ausschließen kann man es nicht
aber alles das muss im blick seien dafür
in drei vier wochen in fünf wochen in
einem monat die ganze weltwirtschaft
immer ein bisschen davor sollten noch
zwei drei wochen zu reden aber haben in
zwei drei wochen sehen wir die menschen
die sich heute infiziert haben das heißt
wir müssen von mehreren solchen zyklen
noch ausgehen und da gibt es für mich
eine schere der vorsitzende des
sachverständigenrats hat heute gesagt
wenn wir diese maßnahmen bis die
wirtschaftlichen maßnahmen bis mai so
weiter fahren dann wird es
wirtschaftlich kritisch kann das nicht
beurteilen ich kann mich da nur auf ihn
berufen wenn wir aber wir müssen aber
davon ausgehen dass dieses corona wie
otto dix bis zum vorhandensein einer
impfung begleiten wird und dass uns
nächstes jahr sein red das ist der grund
warum wir dass die ökonomischen fragen
betrifft jetzt so weit reichende
entscheidung getroffen haben
das gab es 50 milliarden ganz lange
diskutiert werden kann nicht jetzt
irgendwas machen dass drei wochen hält
und dann muss man im april wieder in den
bundestag
und ich habe gesagt wir sind jetzt mutig
und entschieden und wir sagen wir im
westen geben lassen uns vom bundestag
wir bitten darum eine kreditermächtigung
geben von 156 milliarden euro
wir sorgen dafür dass der fonds den wir
zur rettung von unternehmen schon mal in
der finanzkrise für die banden in dem
fall benutzt haben jetzt für die
realwirtschaft genutzt werden kann
riesige rettungsschirm an insgesamt
sechs und wird dann an den mit einer
kreditfähigkeit von 100 milliarden aus
und garantierahmen die noch viel ein
vielfaches größer sind und das führt
dazu dass wir das plausible versprechen
geben können dass wir was durchhalten
können oder lange zeit damit wir immer
in der richtigen reihenfolge entscheiden
das will ich noch mal sagen es geht um
die sicherheit der arbeitsplätze um die
sicherheit und zukunft unseres landes
aber es geht auch um die sicherheit der
bürger und bürger wir sind gesund und
trotzdem müsste ja zur ehrlichkeit
gehören zu sagen herr scholz dass es
manche firmen nicht mehr geben wird und
manche arbeitsplätze nicht mehr geben
wird weil die eben nicht den langen atem
haben deshalb haben wir zum beispiel so
ungewöhnliches gemacht wie ein
zuschussprogramm das auf 50 milliarden
euro und dimensioniert ist wo wir sagen
da wollen wir den leuten den unternehmen
die möglichkeit geben dass sie jetzt
erst mal die erste welle überstehen
können das ist sehr wichtig
zusammen mit den ländern die ähnliche
programme machen
wir sorgen für liquidität das haben wir
unbegrenzt sichergestellt über unsere
förderbank dass die geschäftsbanken die
sparkassen die volksbanken
raiffeisenbanken die privaten banken
weiter kredite geben können wir sorgen
so lebensunterhaltssicherung mit dem
kurzarbeitergeld mit dem zuschuss
familien die wenig verdienen und kinder
haben um solche musiker jetzt passiert
das passiert jetzt
wir haben in anderen sendungen schon
sehr ausführlich darüber gesprochen
welche hoffnungen es eben auf einen
impfstoff oder ein x-beliebiges
medikament gibt das sind antivirale
medikamente die hiv und malaria schon
bekämpft haben an impfstoffen wird
überall in der welt gearbeitet die usa
und china probieren sie an manchen
probanden auch schon aus wenn man komme
risi schätzen denn
auch er nächstes jahr früher nächstes
jahr oder das ist eine ethisch
schwierige frage es gibt heute schon ein
paar impfstoffe getestet werden
aber bevor sie jungen gesunden menschen
flächendeckend zu hunderten millionen
dosen für applizieren müssen sie sicher
sein dass der impfstoff sicher ist und
ich erinnere an die debatte um die
schweinegrippe die wir vor ein paar
jahren hatten wo sich am ende wegen auch
falsche ängste um die sicherheit der
impfstoffe nur etwas über 40 prozent der
bevölkerung überhaupt haben impfen
lassen damals das darf uns hier nicht
wieder passieren deswegen die impfstoffe
müssen sicher sein und ist es sicherheit
auch nicht so dass wir am ersten tag für
80 millionen deutsche impfstoffdosen
haben werden sondern ich glaube weltweit
gibt es im moment eine kapazität von 300
millionen dosen die man im jahr
produzieren kann
das heißt wir werden auch in ein
wettbewerb weltweit hat das haben wir ja
schon gemerkt amerikanischer präsident
der stadt schon versucht ein gutes
deutsches unternehmen zu kaufen
angeblich dann wieder doch nicht also
ist der weg genau und da müssen wir uns
darüber im klaren sein
wir müssen auch über die regeln reden
wir müssen zb darüber reden ob man
bestimmten besonders gefährdeten
personengruppen dann mit etwas
geringeren ethischen samstag wird mir
ganz bange aber da müssen darüber reden
schon den ersten impfstoff geben aber
impfen niemand lässt seine kinder in
gesundheit vor allem wenn wir ihnen
sagen dass bei kindern meistens der
verlauf relativ blende ist lässt seine
kinder impfen hier müssen hier auch als
ärzte ganz viel überzeugungsarbeit noch
landen
und bis dahin haben wir gelernt vermuten
dass wir bei der besteigung des himalaya
es erstmal an das nächste basislager
denkt und dass wir einen guten schärfer
haben mehrere schärfer die den weg schon
mal vorbereiten
langfristig gehen müssen nehmen wir das
als den schlusspunkt ich darf mich ganz
herzlich bedanken für diese diskussion
hier heute abend wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich nächsten donnerstag
wieder ziemlich sicher am nächsten
donnerstag
ansonsten hoffen wir nur uns denken an
sie alle mögen gesund bleiben und gebe
jetzt weiter an nicht markus lanz der am
sonntag
habenicht sendet sondern hier folgt
jetzt zdf-history alle informationen die
sie noch wissen wollen finden sie bei
heute.de und logischerweise auf der
homepage des zdf tschüss bis bald
[Musik]